making Markel clearly in her happy place
makes us happy too I never thought my
life would be that awesome on Wednesday
the Dutchess of Sussex graced fans with
two behind-the-scenes videos from her
workplace capsule collection photoshoot
which she posted to Sussex Royal
Instagram stories in the first clip
Meghan can be seen surprising and
hugging women as they show up to the
shoot the second video features her
directing from the sidelines and even
styling models all while laughing and
smiling herself both videos set to the
1977 Bill Withers hit lovely day offer
fans a sneak peek of Megan's new capsule
clothing collection for the charity
smart works ahead of the autumn launch
according to the Duchess's caption the
collection will equip women entering the
workforce with the key work where
essentials they need she announced the
campaign on Instagram last month and
went on to reveal on the September issue
of British Vogue which she guest edited
that she partnered with designer friend
mission nunu to create the collection
writing quote when you walk into a smart
workspace you're met with racks of
clothing and an array of bags and shoes
sometimes however it can be a potpourri
of mismatched sizes and colors not
always the right stylistic choices or
range of sizes according to Megan the
brand's she's partnered with have agreed
to use the one for one model meaning
that for every item purchased one will
be donated to the charity the Duchess
adds quote not only does this allow us
to be part of each other's story it
reminds us we are in it together women
need a seat at the table
[Music]